the CMA Awards cutest moments but where
was Taylor Swift Plus were with the
Internet Chloe Sevigny hi this is drew
druggie and you're watching The Daily
dinning hello guess who's back in Los
Angeles me New York was a blast and we
have plenty more for my week there for
you guys but today we're heading down to
Nashville
that's where I country's bigger stars
were all in Tennessee last night for the
51st annual CMA Awards but it was one
pop rock star and her daughter who stole
the show pink in her 6 year old willow
where the picture of royalty for the
glamorous mother-daughter date night no
but seriously look how cute these two
are pink in a white tulle creation and
Willow in a dark dress and a tiara fit
for a princess there's nothing like
reading your little girl as your date
and I gotta say pink and Willow are
given Beyonce and Blue Ivy a run for
their money I'd say we need more
daughters going as their mommas date to
these things alright Jesse James Decker
also hit the carpet with her child
except he's still cooking in her belly
the country singer sported the cutest
baby bump Envy dare I say sexiest dress
on the red carpet she and her husband
Tennessee Titan Eric Decker are
expecting their third child a boy
meanwhile Carrie Underwood turned the
CMAs into her own fashion show because
homegirl dazzled in 11 outfit throughout
the night to be fair she was hosting but
my 3 faves were this gorgeous cobalt
blue dress by a designer whose name I
can't pronounce on the red carpet then
the second sparkly number Carrie loves
to shimmer and she's serving us some
Dolly Parton realness but between the
pant and the Cape was easily a favorite
and at one point in the show Carrie wild
in this white alexandrine ball gown for
an emotional tribute to the victims of
the Las Vegas shooting
[Music]
mmm anyone else get chills watching that
we have a full breakdown of Carey CMA
fashion on our website ET online.com now
someone noticed we've missing from the
award show last night taylor swift the
country crooner turned pop princess
proved she still got it because she took
home the CMA for song of the year for
better man which she wrote for Little
Big Town Taylor wasn't there to accept
it but was watching from New York girl
look shocked
shocker Taylor couldn't make you because
she's in New York busy rehearsing for
her SNL appearance I know speaking of
the Big Apple while I was there I got to
hang out with one of my favorite
comedians and performers slash
everything drew druggy best known for
his parody videos as it girl Chloe
Sevigny on YouTube the truth is judogi
plays so many characters I don't know
how he keeps them all straight and now
he's returning off Broadway for his
hilarious solo play bright colors and
bold patterns so for people who haven't
seen the show set it up for him
okay so bright colors and bold patterns
is set the night before a gay wedding in
Palm Springs oh my god gay wedding like
they all like that as they should be I'm
playing a character who is I going
through a bit of a crisis the night
before the wedding and he shows up a
ready to party ready to hold court
yeah and ruins things pretty much the
night before the wedding so the party
and you know and I just wanted to raise
a lot of questions about where we are in
gay culture and with gay marriage and
just marriage in general and pushing 40
and figuring out where you are in your
life and sort of now all of a sudden
like we have this big adult you know
opportunity in front of us that we've
never had before and you know and call
some ruckus to elevate Coronas and
margaritas I'm with you on that please
refrain from wearing bright colors or
bold patterns
so let me ask you this what kind of
wedding guests are you in real life I'm
actually a blubbering mess I went to I
went to my friend's wedding recently and
I just I couldn't stop crying
I'm embarrassed how I am like I wish I
was like the character I'm playing in
this show is just like catty and over it
and like oh great you're in love how
nice you know me and I sit there and I'm
like oh my god you have flowered your
head like I'm just an idiot I'm not
complete idiot one of my favorite
characters that you play of course is
Chloe Sevigny I mean that's how I was
introduced to you actually he's like
finding Chloe online you're the
Internet's Chloe how much fun now you
haven't done a video in a long time it
has been a while it's been a video yes
and then just because we've gotten busy
but she's not going anymore
she's not going away I mean I've been
doing the character for so long it's
such a part of me it is but I love it
and I love that people still watch it
and still like it because it was an idea
I had 15 years ago it's so great um and
I can't believe it's still banging
around and that people still like it
good evening America I'm Chloe Sevigny
it's recently come to my attention that
I am mo dead has she seen it she has
seen it yes yes and we've met we years
ago we met at a party and she was really
lovely and it's awkward it's weird
because it's her but it's not her I
really I really admire her and thing I
think she's awesome and I'm not out to
knock her down it's not these fears I've
said so many villains in this world
Chloe Sevigny has not won right exactly
if you're in New York you got to go
check out jus in this play plus you get
a margarita out of it bright colors bold
patterns begins previews November 12th
and is at the Soho Playhouse through
January 7 oh my god join us ound like in
like a New Yorker right didn't think so
alright well tomorrow as promised I'll
be bringing you guys my night at the
20th anniversary of the Lion King on
Broadway and more from Elton John who
may or may not be contributing to the
live-action film and on Monday we are
celebrating 100 episodes of the daily
Denny so ring the bell or else you're
gonna miss it do it now okay love you
guys bye
[Music]